I have no BGM.
Wait.
I forgot.
It's so quiet.
One moment, please.
One moment.
Wait, is this one good?
Oh.
One second?
I'll do this one.
My, my, my.
Hello!
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hello, hello, hello.
Hi, hi, hi.
Wow, wait, I just realized.
Thank you so much for all the gifted.
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Hello, and Tadaiima again.
Oh yeah.
I straightened earlier today.
about an hour ago actually yes and now I'm here I'm
streaming again moey moey boo moey moey boo Mickey is live
Mickey is live I'm after live you look absolutely stunning
today two minto's in one day oh good garly For a single
choice, thank you so much for the gifted.
You guys, for those who didn't see, my jazz show has now a
second show.
It's a late night show.
It's actually quite late.
It starts at 11.30 p.m.
I prayed to my god, Amin, to ask for a 3-day weekend, and I
got it.
Yeah!
Let's go to the real world.
Three day weekend!
Yes, so...
I have the second show!
And...
Tickets are not up yet.
Check the Oshi Spark page for...
for...
For more details.
But...
my brain has been so like learning everything for the uh
show that i was like wait i didn't think of like any songs
to sing for today will there be an online version yes it
will also be streamed so there will be streaming uh tickets
as well so yes yes yes please come one come all worldwide
anybody can watch any news on streaming tickets what kind of
news like windows will go up i think they're going up next
week from what i understand i
think so so yeah and karaoke is the best way to start the
weekend yeah i originally uh had something that i wanted
that i thought might be ready today but it's not so i was
like oh well you know i'll still do the karaoke that's okay
i'm i'm just now like i'm now i'm just kind of like i don't
know what am i seeing i i usually like go i i did go through
like some like songs i was like oh i could sing this i could
sing that but today i'm mostly just like Sorry, I thought I
don't know what I was thinking I was going to say I thought,
but actually that's the thing I wasn't thinking at all I
wasn't thinking at all
That's okay though And then I'm gonna have to take Wait, oh
I will have to take a little Well, my water is quite warm
I'm just going to say I'll have to take a break later
Because I started Cooking up some hot water I have like a
big S Silk Sonic.
Hmm?
I, um, what was it?
I was cooking up some hot water.
And I have one of those, like, water dispensers that keeps
it warm, like, all day.
But I just refilled it.
And then I was like, okay, time to get my hot water.
And then I was like, no!
She cooking!
Are you a water microwaver?
Absolutely not.
I have my thing.
I have my...
my...
dispenser.
My... it's not a kettle.
I microwave everything.
What?
I
just call it a hot water boiler.
It's not a kettle though.
Right?
Zoji Rushi dispenser is the truth.
You guys, for real though!
With the amount of hot water I drink on a daily basis, like
I need it.
It's not a kettle.
It's a hot water dispenser.
And I will die on that hill.
I died on that hill.
I'm dead.
One other thing, another way that I get, I actually like
find a bunch of songs that I want to sing through TikTok
actually.
But my TikTok has been...
sad sad tick tocks about dinosaur the ride closing like
literally i the other night i got like five in a row i've i
got i got so many and they make me cry every time can we go
on dinosaur the ride together what if i find like a good cam
a good pov after a couple songs can we ride dinosaur the
We'll just do a POV together.
Yeah?
Okay.
Because I only got to go on it one time.
And I was like, maybe I'll do another trip, I thought.
And then prices, plane prices were so expensive.
I said I should not do that.
I've never been on Dinosaur of the Ride.
Is it fun?
Oh, golly.
Okay, there's a storyline to it.
There's a storyline to it.
So, you are...
Okay, hold on.
There's actually a whole storyline to Dino Land in Disney's
Animal Kingdom.
So, the storyline is that there was a small town and they
found, like, a ton of dinosaur fossils, right?
They found a ton of dinosaurs fossils in their small town.
And so, a bunch of paleontologists, and everything, they all
started coming in and grew and it was kind of like a gold
rush in a way, but with fossils.
And this is all inside the theme park, okay?
Like this is all the lore of this area of the theme park,
which is kind of rare.
Like not a lot of theme parks do like lore anymore.
Everything also has a stinking IP.
So it's very frustrating.
Like we're losing, we're losing original concepts in theme
parks.
Okay, I need to stop because I'm not gonna, This is my
niche, okay?
Anyway, I will get worked up.
I will get worked up.
Okay, but anyway, so all these people come flooding.
And so the, just a small town, so hard.
So they try to capitalize off of all these people coming to
see the fossils.
So, the theming of Dinoland, right now, a lot of the stuff
was torn down because they're building things for the new
theme that they'll be building.
But it used to be very like, the theme was run down, like
tourist trap, tourist attraction, like the most rinkity,
rinkity, dinkity, like, side road attraction that you can
think of that was that was like the theming of dinoland and
like there were billboards it kind of told the story through
like you know it was a visual storytelling so you would see
like a billboard that would say like turn left here parking
is 50 cents and then they would cross out the 50 cents and
like big red paint and it said like parking is now one
dollar things like that you know and so the dinosaur the
ride is This is this institute that came to study the
fossils.
They're like the Dinosaur Institute.
They're like this kind of like their funding is basically
being cut.
Like they're not so in demand anymore.
Like Dino Land is kind of like...
It's actually kind of true to real life because Dino Land is
now leaving.
And it's not popular anymore.
But...
It's kind of like...
the lore of Dinoland where people don't go to Dinoland
anymore in the this fictional town in the theme park right
and so they're doing their studies at the Dinosaur Institute
and the ride is you are getting your own tour they're
they're gonna send you back to the Crestaceous period and
you're gonna go around and explore but one of the guys there
he's just like hey what if we make this like iguanodon that
i want to study and the lady is just like uh no you're not
uh you were going on a nice tour he was like i have located
a iguanodon but it's like really close to like the meteors
but you guys will make it and and and they're like they're
like they're like no you're gonna send way before the
meteors, because that's dangerous.
And they're like, he's like, yeah, you're totally right.
And then she leaves, and he's like, actually, I totally
hacked the system, and I'm going to send you to go get that
Aguadon.
Okay, get out of here.
And stop making fun of the way I say it, okay?
You guys always make fun of me.
Shut up.
Crestatious.
There you go.
Are you happy?
Oh my God.
Anyway, I'm telling you a story.
you a story and so you go and you go and and you're like
stop me but wait there's no esch have I been spelling it
wrong this whole time wait no way quit quit tate oh wait
I've been spelling it wrong.
Wait, I can't even spell anymore.
Anyways, stop, guys.
I'm getting excited, okay?
Cretaceous.
Oh my gosh.
What?
Why did I...
I can't read.
It doesn't matter.
Well, it does matter.
Oh, no.
This is like a jaguar all over again.
Don't say that.
No!
crustaceous.
It does kind of sound like a crustacean.
Maybe I was confusing it with crabs.
Maybe that's why I always said it wrong.
That's so funny.
Anyway, you go back in time and you're just like, okay,
we're driving around.
We gotta go find the iguanodon.
You look at this and you're like, nope, not our dino.
Okay, look at this and you're just like, no, maneuver left,
maneuver right.
Oh my god, the meteors are coming down.
Go, go, go.
And then you see like a
Why can't I remember his name right now?
Now I'm all psyched up.
You see...
Carnotaurus!
You see the carnotaurus.
Wait, is it?
Yeah?
Okay, good.
Yeah, definitely not our dino.
Yeah, he sees it and he's just like...
He's like, go, go, go!
Yeah, you see the carnotaurus.
Which I remember, I think it was, there was somebody in the
group that last time I went, and they were like, yeah, you
got to run from the T-Rex.
And I was like, no, there's no T-Rexes on this ride.
It's Carnotaurus, please.
Understand.
Please understand.
You are so rock.
But anyway, I can't say shit.
I just said crustaceous.
Like a crab.
It's fine.
And...
Hey, at least, you know, I'd admit when I'm wrong, and I
will be corrected.
Not a lot of people, some people will double down, okay?
Anyway, so you finally, it's like, it's like 30 seconds to
impact.
Like, it is, time is of the essence.
And finally, in the, like, final 10 seconds, you see him,
the Aguadon, and he is tree-hunting.
hugging and you're like grab that guy you literally like you
like wrestle him into the cart and you grab him and then the
guy at the end he's like you're not gonna make it they're
not gonna make it and then he's just like they made it and
that's the end of the ride it's like so intense it's so
great it's so great and then very it's so cute because
afterwards you see like you see like security footage of of
like the area of like the laboratory and everything and and
uh you see like the iguana don just like walking around in
the back rooms but it's so cute it's such a good ride it's
so fun and it's like basically the same track almost
identical to Indiana Jones which is what the ride is going
to become But I still...
I still want it to be dinosaurs.
You sold me on it.
Yeah, well, you have less than 20 days to go.
I think it's like...
The last day to ride it is February 1st.
So...
What if
Indiana Jones rode dinosaurs?
I wish.
Hashtag not my dinosaur.
Not my dino.
I'm gonna go ride it in Sunday.
I'm so jealous.
Have fun.
And what's crazy is, like, technically the dinosaur ride is
based off of an IP, but...
It's technically...
I'm pretty sure I wrote it when I was on Countdown to
Extinction.
I remember that ride, too.
I always skip Dinoland because I never realized I was there
I just thought it was a kitty area no what IP is based off
of a movie called dinosaur but like it's not very popular at
all but the thing is is it's only the iguanodon and the
carnitores that are like in that movie like it's based off
of those characters but it's completely like the dinosaur
institute everything is is completely separate so man i'm
not sure adding indian 2026 will make it that more popular
in the long term dinos are forever i know i'm very torn i
don't know what's up with this like indiana jones resurgence
we got the game we had that newer like i say newer because
it came out what last year or the year before we had that
movie um but but harrison ford that was like the could do as
Indiana Jones, I think.
We're not getting anymore.
So I don't know.
Oh, it was 2024.
Okay.
Like, I don't think we're getting anymore.
The land was once sponsored by McDonald's, and you can still
see...
Yes!
You can still see pipes that have chemical compounds of
ketchup, mustard, and mayonnaise.
You can!
Yeah.
So, literally...
The Isle of Destiny was his MGS4.
You can't do him anymore.
You can't.
No more Indiana Jones.
You can't do that anymore.
Let me take a sipy.
I'm sorry for getting excited about Dinosaur.
Actually, we should ride it right now.
No, I should sing first.
No, let me get it out of my system.
Let me get it out of my system.
He belongs in a museum.
Yeah.
Dinosaur, rod, POV.
Let's see.
I think I watched this one.
Hold on.
I'm turning off the audio real quick.
Or I did watch this one, but I think what I meant to say is
I remember.
I think it was good.
Okay.
Yeah.
We can do from...
Oh, we can start from sound.
Oh yeah, okay.
I don't think there's talking or anything, too.
Okay, one second.
One second.
Okay, it's just a 10-minute video, guys.
No, no.
This is a no-brainer.
Why wouldn't we ride dinosaur the ride?
It's fine.
It's okay.
I'll even get small.
Okay, hold on.
Move.
Move me.
Where am I?
Here.
Okay, let's watch.
Let's watch.
Dinosaur the Rod.
Can you hear it?
Look!
I stood there!
yeah it's so fun and the queue is so cute it's like a little
museum
wow why is he looking at us like that
short person pov no
it's the iguana don't we're gonna go There's the
Carnotaurus.
And he's like, wah!
Which I get to, Rex's, like, but the Carnotaurus is so much
cooler looking, in my opinion.
There's, it's a dark and scary dinosaur place.
What's the cue?
Guys, it's only a 10 minute wait.
We got this.
Welcome, friend.
You're welcome.
Welcome!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
monsters look it's like a museum for real it's so awesome
wait did we just go into the light we didn't know we didn't
go in the lightly lightning lane did we wow we're gonna not
have this anymore
so cool
right on into your right hand side please okay the dine
that's the dinosaur institute logo okay we're We're gonna go
watch the intro movie.
Oh, why?
It already started?
Like, yeah, we're going to the Time Rover, you guys.
That's proprietary.
It's a breathtaking journey through a prehistoric world.
It's the most spectacular creatures to ever walk the earth.
In a moment, you'll be going live to our control center for
a comprehensive safety briefing, and then it's on to the
tour that will convince you forever that the future is truly
in the past
yeah oh my god this is my guy welcome to our little
transdimensional joyride folks i'm dr seeker your friendly
controller and a heck of a paleontologist if i do say so
myself but let's not talk about me let's talk about you and
how you can help me this video i wonder how old this is
truly If I can bring you back from the Cretaceous period, he
said it!
I can bring back a live dinosaur with you.
I want a Cretaceous period.
Take a look at this guy.
That's the Aquanidata.
See, these are scenes from the movie.
He is the key to understanding these magnificent creatures.
I don't think I've ever seen this movie.
As old as the ride.
Yeah, they've never updated it ever.
Right now, our dino should be about here at the very end of
the Cretaceous period.
That's where you're going to be.
Just kidding, we're not going.
Dr. Marsh.
That is impossible to close to the giant asteroid impact
that destroyed most life forms on Earth.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
It's probably on VHS still.
It's gotta be.
And I'm going to show you that all time rovers have been
securely locked on the Earth's force.
The crustaceous period is far in the future.
That's why the crabs take over the world.
Securely locked.
Access denied.
Continued.
We were just talking about seatbelts.
It's so cute the way they do this.
You can get kind of choppy out there, so I'll keep her hands
and arms inside the middle at all times.
Whoa, it's going to get bumpy, guys.
Last photography, I wouldn't.
It alters the homing signal, and that's not good.
Oh, and one more thing.
That was locked coordinates.
We're in.
Now, here's the drill.
You follow the homing signal to the iguanodon.
Then, I'll enlarge the transport field, and boom, you're
back with one additional passenger extra large.
Extra large.
about that asteroid they'll be able to out of their footing
and breaks the atmosphere trust me what could go wrong we
could go wrong sorry hey it's me again remember only you
guys are going on the special only us don't tell anyone
don't tell anyone it's kind of messed up don't tell anybody
i don't want to hear the people talking keep going wait okay
oh you can probably see the pipes in
Carcinization mention.
There they are, see those pipes here?
That's your ketchup, a mayo, and your maestro.
Don't tell anyone.
Wow, the Dino Institute welcomes us!
The future is in!
It's in!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my
god, oh my god, we're so in!
We're in!
And the time rovers, okay, honestly, they look exactly like
the Indiana Jones carts, so that's really easy to like
repurpose.
I wish dinosaurs were real.
We have dinosaurs.
Apparently birds are starting to, like, show some signs of
evolution in that they're regrowing teeth in their beaks.
Isn't that, like, kind of crazy?
Oh.
Time travel commencing in T-minus 10 seconds.
Here we go, guys.
Oh, my God.
This is Seeker.
Listen up.
We got to get in, grab the Aquanadon, and get held before
the Astro.
Yeah, baby.
Let's roll!
Oh my gosh, we're going back in time.
Whoa!
Look at the car.
It's like rolling.
Woo!
Okay, now let's go get that dino.
Let's go get that dino!
What are you tracking?
That's Dyracosaurus.
Not our dino.
No.
Oh, here comes my favorite one right there.
Here's my favorite animatronic.
It's so gnarly.
Hashtag not our dino.
Time to get serious.
Autokilic.
Hang on!
Oh my gosh.
I'm tracking a big dino on the scope.
Could be ours.
Nope, that's not our dino.
Definitely not our dino.
Go!
Oh my god.
It's so dark.
I love Dark Brides though.
And identify.
Still not our dinosaur.
Saurapod.
Still not our dino, but at least this one's a vegetarian.
At least this one's a vegetarian!
The neck flapping I know is so funny.
They look so good still.
Uh-oh.
90 seconds, guys.
Interadactal.
Incoming!
Oh my god.
Keep going, keep going!
Keep going!
Computer, what's happening?
Loss of traction.
Uh-oh.
We got a maneuver!
Four-wheel drive!
Move it!
would be so scary for a kid.
Oh my god.
That's where they take your picture.
That's it.
Abort.
No.
There he is.
They made it.
Did
you guys think we were gonna Crazy.
Wait, I want to see if they have a video.
Oh, yeah, here, here, here.
You see like him wandering around this time.
And they're like looking for him and they're like, oh,
there's like a dinosaur that is just wandering around the
facility.
It's so cute.
I'm all like worked up now.
good oh my gosh it's so good
it's giving me flashbacks to vid playing Jurassic Park the
arcade except we don't have to pan handle for our quarters
every 12 seconds oh the ride is so awesome like this just
the amount of of like oh my god terror is this happening is
so intense it's they're just like oh my god you you like you
have to get out now you have 30 seconds like it's so crazy
oh my gosh 5 chance of death for immersion
oh man the amount of lore is really impressive right it
scared me so much as a kid that i wanted to go home four
states away it was our first ride uh thank you guys for
letting us ride uh dinosaur that was so fun Thank you.
Thanks for humoring me.
Thank you for humoring.
I'll sing now.
I'll sing now, I promise.
Oh, it's so good.
So good.
All right, Steiner, I understand no Super Bowl, but what if
we buy Dinosaur and keep it for Dinosaur?
setsu land so true so true he's so fun can we have a theme
park ride stream someday really would you want that it's
great seeing you so happy watching that because it's like
the best ride ever oh it's so fun i'm glad we could ride it
together let's see what should i sing today i plan on
singing just kind of whatever um uh i want to sing japanese
songs too i was thinking like maybe i was listening to a
bunch of uh what's the word um like you know old school
anime openings and stuff like i was listening to like sakura
wars and stuff last night so um it just made me think um
maybe like a classic anime opening but i would have to i do
have my switch set up, I would just have to, like, get it.
Get it going.
But basically, the way it works on Joy Sound for the Switch
is that you
have like a time limit.
I know, the Sakura Wars theme is so good.
Could it go today then?
Maybe.
Sing whatever.
Walk the dinosaur.
Have we seen Alien Encounter?
Yes, so good.
So good.
Seen any of the Battlefield Bad Company trailers.
Despite being a military shooter, it's a comedy, and the
trailers make fun of a ton of military games, including
Metal Gear.
Wait, I'll check it out later.
Oh my goddess.
Oh my god, I was thinking that too!
Wait, but like I didn't watch the original, oh my goddess.
I watched like the reboot.
Like it was, it's still old, but the one with Ishida Yoko
did the opening, I remember.
What song?
What's like a song that represents me and dinosaur?
The ride.
Love a whole live stream just reacting to your favorite
rides.
Also, here's my contribution to the fun of my dinosaur.
Yeah, y'all?
Oh, maybe.
I feel like it's almost react content if I'm just like,
okay, now we're going to ride this.
We're going to watch a POV of this ride.
But it would be fun for me.
Standing in Akiva right now, Minto.
This stuff is no game.
What's no game mean?
What do you mean by that?
Andrey goes, thank you so much for the thank you.
Let's see.
Wait,
what am I looking for?
One second.
Oh, I remember.
This is like my go-to song when I think of, of when I think
of something that I love.
So, I'm gonna sing it.
Sorry.
One second.
Redo?
Why do birds suddenly appear?
Every time you are near, just like me, they long to be close
to you.
Why do stars fall down from the sky?
Oh my god, they're not going to make it.
Every time you walk by, they made it.
Just like me, they long to be close to you.
On the day that you were born, the angels got together To
create a dream come true So they sprinkle moon dust in your
hair And golden starlight in your eyes of blue That is why
all the girls in town Follow you all around Just like me
They longed to be close to you.
On the day that you were born, the angels got together and
decided to create a dream come true.
So they sprinkled moon dust in your hair and golden
starlight in your eyes of blue.
That is why all the girls in town follow you all around.
Just like me, they long to be close to you.
Love
close to you.
audio.
Ah,
close to you.
Ah, close to you.
dinosaur.
I'm gonna miss you so much.
I'm gonna miss you dinosaur.
So good.
So good, man.
Let's see what else we got.
I'm gonna do.
Let's see.
Oh, what's this?
Hmm.
Sakura Wars was one of my favorites.
I even played all the original games on a special edition
Sakura Wars Dreamcast.
I'd use a translation guide.
Oh my gosh, that's crazy.
I'll be honest.
I didn't watch it.
I'll be 100% honest.
But the opening is so good.
Just that.
It's so...
Oh,
it's so good.
Um, let's see.
Hmm.
Okay, actually, now this one's also about dinosaur.
Sorry.
I'll stop.
Every night in my dreams, I see you.
I feel you, that is how I know you.
Go on.
It's my Celine Dion impression.
Far across the distance and spaces between us, you have come
to show you.
Go on.
Near, far, wherever you are, I believe that the heart does
go on.
Once more, you open the door and you're here in my heart and
my heart will go on and on.
I have to do like this funky thing with my mouth every time
I sing.
Love can touch us one time and last for a lifetime And never
let go till we're gone Love was when I loved you One true
time I hold to in my life will always go on.
Near, far, wherever you are, I believe that the heart does
go on.
Once you open the door And you're here in my heart And my
heart will go on and on I can't do it anymore
Okay, I'm not serious for now, serious Okay, this is...
Not Celine Dion, this is me too dinosaur.
I am here.
There's nothing I fear.
And I know that my heart will go on.
We'll stay forever.
Oh,
this song's not over.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, we're done with dinosaur lamenting.
I think I got it out of my system.
I love this totally normal karaoke stream.
Okay, what should I say?
Oh, shoot.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
I'm, like, so unserious.
Oh, my gosh.
The Aguadadon could have fit in the time.
God.
I'll sacrifice myself.
Put me in the Cretaceous period.
I love crabs.
What do you mean?
It's the Cretaceous period.
Oh, no.
I'll go to Japan for the first time in February I want to
ask you for recommendations Everyone says something
different but I trust you PN, especially for Akihabara I
don't know, oh gosh, it always is what you want to do I
recommend February Might be kind of cold but I recommend And
Oshima, always, always, always
Never be serious We're just here to be silly, no
um let's see what else do i want to sing i mean there's
always so much i want to sing i just like singing it's fun
it's silly um i'm like going through like the popular songs
on uh on what's it called um caro fun so except mossburger
what do you mean except mossburger
and that seems so nice i love I love it.
Let me take a sip here.
Um, lately there's been this one song I don't watch or
watch.
I don't I don't listen to 21 pilots, but like a bunch of fan
edits of this one song by them has been like circulating a
lot.
It's called drag path ours.
I think or that's like one of the names of it.
like they haven't released the song yet and so people are
like just like begging for them to to release it and i it's
been stuck in my head but like there's no way to sing it
because the song is not released but it's so like i just get
like literally i'll be like brushing my teeth i'll be
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, Valentine.
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
That song is never getting released for reason.
Inexplicable.
I have no idea.
I don't know any lore.
I just know that people are like crying for the song.
And I'm like, I don't know.
It's a good song.
I don't know what's going on.
Okay, here's my last song to Dinosaur, but it's me moving
on.
I heard that you're settled down, that you found a girl and
you're married now.
I heard that your dreams came true.
Guess she gave you things.
I didn't give to you It's like an iguanodon Hold, friend Why
are you so shy?
Ain't like you to hold back
I hate to turn up out of the blue uninvited But I couldn't
stay away I couldn't fight it I'd hoped you'd see my face
And that you'd be reminded that for me It isn't over over
it?
Wait a second.
Never mind, I'll find someone like you.
I wish nothing but the best for you too.
Don't forget me, I beg, I remember you said.
Sometimes it lasts in love, but sometimes it hurts instead.
Sometimes it lasts in love but sometimes it hurts instead
time flies oh my god the future is in the past yesterday it
was the time of our lives we were born and raised in a
summer haze bound by this surprise of our glory I hate to
turn up out of the blue, uninvited, but I couldn't stay
away, I couldn't fight it.
I'd hoped you'd see my face, and that for me, you'd be
reminded that for me, it isn't over.
Mind how fine someone like you, I wish nothing but the best
for you to Don't forget me, I bear who you said Sometimes it
lasts in love, but sometimes it hurts instead Nothing
compares, no worries or cares Regrets and mistakes their
memories make Who would have known how bittersweet this
would take?
I wish nothing but the best for you too Don't forget me, I
beg, I remember you said Sometimes it lasts in love, but
sometimes it hurts instead Never mind, I'll find someone
like you I wish nothing but the best for you best for you
too don't forget me I beg I remember you said sometimes it
lasts in love but sometimes it hurts instead sometimes it
lasts in love but sometimes it hurts instead
I forgot to turn on the camera angles
Yay.
Oh, dinosaur.
We will never forget you.
Oh, we don't.
Thank you.
Thank you now.
Thank you so much for that.
Go show, bye, thank you.
Goodbye, dinosaur.
I'll find another ride like you.
Maybe.
Probably not.
Walk the dinosaur.
I don't know that song.
I know it, but I don't.
Are there any other words besides get on the floor?
Wait, there's two voices in this?
Oh, okay.
Is this the song?
I lit a cigarette, picked up a monkey's goal to go.
So I was spitting fire.
This time I was blue as ice.
I felt a little tired.
So I washed my amulise.
I walked the dinosaur.
Ah!
Rock the dinosaur!
Open the floor!
Open the door, get on the floor!
Everybody rock the dinosaur!
I met you in a cave!
I said, I'll be your slave!
Follow wherever you go!
What am I singing?
The night we split a rattlesnake and danced beneath the
stars.
You fell asleep Star stayed awake and watch the passing
cars.
Well, you walk the dinosaur and I walk the dinosaur.
Open the door.
Let's go.
dinosaur.
Open the door.
The floor.
Everybody walk the dinosaur.
Give out the floor.
On the floor.
Everybody walk the dinosaur.
One night I dreamed of New York You and I are roasting blue
pork In the statue of Liberty's torch Am I close to how the
original is?
Alphys landed in a rock rock rocket ship Healed a couple
of...
I don't know what the rest of your sentence says.
Oh, Sky, too much big bird!
Kill the dinosaur!
No!
We're not killing him, please!
Nobody kill the dinosaur!
Open the floor, get on the floor!
No, I said floor again.
The floor!
Everybody kill the...
No!
Open the door, get on the floor!
Nobody kill the dinosaur!
on the floor nobody killed a dinosaur I don't like this song
I hated that song
you fix the song we're not killing the dinosaur what the
hell why would they say that in hindsight not an ideal
choice We are killing the dinosaur because the ride is
dying.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, let's see.
Let's go back to like top songs.
Oh, top 80s.
Let's see that.
I've been in like 80s mood recently.
Imagine how much Dino Nuggy is that one.
be that's true abba
i would always love abba i feel like i always sing the same
abba song so because i don't know so many oh
um wait
hold on let me remember how this starts
maybe we could do this one this one is dinosaur sorry This
one is...
Dinosaur to everybody else.
Won't you come see about me?
I'll be alone Dancing, you know it baby Tell me your
troubles and doubts Giving me everything inside and out And
little strange, so real in the dark Tender things that we
were working on Slow change may pull us apart When the light
gets into your heart, baby Don't you forget about me Don't
you forget about me
You stand above me Look my
eyes rain keeps falling rain keeps falling down dies
me call my name or walk on by rain keeps falling rain keeps
falling down down
don't you try to pretend it's my feeling we'll win in the
end I won't harm you Touch your defenses, vanity and
security Oh, don't you forget about me I'll be alone dancing
you know it, baby Go away to take you apart I'll put us back
together at heart, baby Sorry, don't you forget about me
won't you
walk on by my name as you walk on by will you call my name
when you walk away
or will you walk off
think of the rain as like the meteors and then will you call
my will you walk
Yay!
That was...
Um...
That was Don't You.
Forget about me.
From Simple Minds.
Very nice.
What else is in here?
Oh, I love this song too.
Okay, I'm gonna sing this one too.
Wait.
If you know Tarzan, you should sing, You'll be in my heart.
Oh, you'll be in my heart.
Oh, you'll be in my heart From this day on Now and
forevermore You'll be in my heart You'll be in my heart
That's gonna destroy you No way Maybe this song will destroy
you I
bet I hear the Clock tick and think of you Caught up in
circles Confusion is nothing new Flashbacks, warm nights
Almost left behind Suitcases, memories Time after sometimes
You picture me I'm walking too far away ahead you're calling
to me i can't hear what you've said then you say go slow i
fall behind the second hand unwise if you're lost you can
look and you will find me time after time if you fall i will
catch you i'll be waiting Time after time If you're lost,
you can look and you will find me Time after time If you
fall, I will catch you, I'll be waiting Time after time My
picture fades and darkness has turned to grey Watching
through windows, you're wandering If I'm okay Secrets stolen
From deep inside The drum beats out of time If you're lost,
you can look and you will find me Time after time If you
fall, I will catch you, I'll be waiting Time after time
You said go slow, I fall behind The second hand unwinds If
you're lost, you can look and you will find me Time after
time If you fall, I will catch you, I'll be waiting Time
after time If you're lost, you can look and you will find me
Time after time.
If you fall, I will catch you.
I will be waiting.
Time after time.
Yeah.
Yippee!
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I love that song.
It's like one of my favorite songs ever.
For real.
As a time traveler, that's one of my favorite songs.
You want a song that always reduces me to sobbing messes as
the world caves in?
Oh, wait, that song is so good!
But I only sing the girl, the cover, the girl, the cover
did.
Or, no, but, wait.
Sorry, the cover, the girl did.
Not the original, sorry.
The girl, the cover did.
No.
I was speaking dyslexic.
I'm sorry.
Hold on, let me drink for this one.
Okay, the song is so sad.
We'll do happy songs after this one.
I feel it are raking.
My...
Wait, sorry.
Can I restart?
One second.
I have to remember how it goes in the beginning.
It's been a minute.
Hold on, let me hear it real quick.
Can you sing for me?
Sing for me!
My feet are aching Your back is pretty tired Okay, I got it,
I got it, I got it, I got it I got it, I got it Okay, okay
My feet are aching And your back is pretty tired And we've
drunk a couple bottles, babe And set our grief aside The
papers say it's Doomsday The button has been pressed We're
gonna nuke each other up, boys Till old Satan stands
impressed And here it is Our final night alive to the
ground.
Oh boy, it's you.
Locks in.
I watch TV with as the world, as the world cares in.
your finest suit on I paint my fingernails Oh, we're going
out in style, babe And everything's on sale We creep up on
extinction I pull your arms right in I weep and say
goodnight, love While my organs pack it in And here it is,
our final night alive As the earth burns to the ground Oh
boy, it's you That I lie with As the atom of black's in Oh
boy, it's you I watch TV with As the world As the world
caves in
Chantong So sad!
So sad!
Let's see, what else have we got?
What Abba do we have?
Happy song time?
No.
Wait, I thought of another song that I was thinking of the
other day and I was like, oh I can sing this during karaoke.
Oh my god, this is a throwback though.
Is it flamb?
Okay, after this flamb.
After this flamb.
If Minto's singing, I'ma crawl out through the fallout.
Shadow Cross, thank you so much for the tag.
Thank you.
Okay.
Kind of has the same mood as I'd Stop the World.
I'd Stop the World.
I'm out with you.
That one.
Okay, this is another sad song.
Oh my gosh, wait, though.
This is like so...
This is like...
When...
Okay, this is like this era of like emo kid, you know?
But it's like not emo song, but you...
Okay, you'll know when you hear it.
Okay, and then we'll do flamb.
Oh my god, hearing it again is crazy.
Hey there, Delilah, what's it like in New York City?
I'm a thousand miles away, but girl, tonight you look so
pretty.
Yes you do.
Times Square can't shine as bright as you.
I swear it's true.
Oh, it's so low.
Hey there, Delilah, don't you worry about the distance?
I'm right there if you get lonely.
Give this song another listen, close your eyes.
Listen to my voice, it's my disguise I'm by your side Oh,
it's what you do to me Oh, it's what you do to me Oh, it's
what you do to me Oh, it's what you do to me What you do to
me Hey there, Delilah, I know times are getting hard But
just believe me, girl, someday I'll pay the bills with this
guitar We'll have it good We'll have the lie word is good
Hey there, Delilah, I've got so much left to say If every
simple song I wrote to you Would take your breath away, I'd
write it off Even more in love with me, you'd fall We'd have
it all Oh, it's what you do to me Oh, it's what you do to me
Oh, it's what you do to me
A thousand miles seems pretty far But they've got planes and
trains and cars I'd walk to you if I had no other way Our
friends would all make fun of us But we'll just laugh along
because we know that none of them have felt this way.
Delilah, I can promise you that by the time that we get
through the world will never ever be the same, and you're to
blame.
Hey there, Delilah, you'll be good and don't you miss me.
Two more years and you'll be done with school, and I'll be
making history like I do.
We
can do whatever we want
This one's for you
Oh, it's what you do to me Oh, it's what you do to me Oh,
it's what you do to me
Too low How do you even go?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
It's too long!
I love playing my cheese so glad I got to hear you sing one
of their songs you should sing hate I really don't like you.
I really really don't like you it's a fun song.
Wait I think I know that one.
Oh whatever wait go away Sakana do you know any Gundam
songs?
Go away what are you doing here?
I'm not on Japanese songs.
Actually, how long have I been streaming?
Or, oh, well, I talked for a long time, almost an hour about
dinosaur, and then I sang a bunch of songs about dinosaur.
I'm not that sick of English songs yet.
What's, like, a new song?
Let's see.
Wait, how does this one go again?
I don't
know, I don't think I remember it enough.
Dang it.
I must see.
Chapelle Roan.
Did she, wait, didn't she, was there a new song?
Or am I crazy?
Oh, or am I thinking of the subway?
I could try subway.
Fall on angel propane and stalking.
I just, I just said.
No anime songs yet.
Oh, Flambe!
I wrote it down even.
Wait, what was that song?
What's that song called?
What's the Flambe song called?
Oh, I'm a bird.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, wait, hold on.
Let me see if I can find his lyrics.
Song lyrics.
Oh my gosh!
Wait.
Oh, here we go.
He just yaps the whole song.
Oh my god.
Okay, we'll do Chapel Row and after.
What's this song?
It's just called Bitch.
I'm a bitch.
Oh, wait, no.
Wow, there's a lot of songs that contain the word bitch.
Wait.
What's it?
Who is it by?
Oh, Meredith Brooks.
Oh, oh, it's the very first one.
Okay, I thought it was called I'm a bitch.
Oh, no, this is Subway.
Okay, never mind.
Well, it sounds like hip-hop, but it's not.
Because then the white guitar comes in.
Oh, oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I hate the world today.
You're so good to me.
I know but I can't change.
I can't change!
I tried to tell you but you look at me like maybe I'm an
angel underneath innocent and sweet.
Yesterday I cried sour and sweet sweet and sour sauce.
Oh you have no music!
Oh sounds like hip hop but it's not.
Oh yeah, the guitar comes in.
Oh yeah, mmm, mmm.
It's like, right, DMZ?
So what is he yapping about?
Oh my god.
I hate the world today.
You're so good to me, I know, but I can't change.
I can't change!
I tried to tell you, but you look at me like maybe.
I'm an angel underneath.
Innocent and sweet, like sweet and sour sauce.
Yesterday I cried.
I've been totally to see the softer side So, so, so!
Alright, back up, sing for me.
I can't understand.
Help you be so confused.
I don't envy you.
I'm a little bit of everything.
All rolled into one.
I'm a bitch.
My name's Robert, such a bitch whose name is Robert.
I'm a bitch, yeah, I'm a bitch.
I'm such a fucking bitch.
I have no hopes, have no dreams, And a tiny little peal and
it doesn't even function anyway Because I'm a rectile
dysfunction Time to take a look to me as I am Just a tiny
little bitch of a man Rest assured that when I start to make
you nervous I'm going to extremes Tomorrow I will change and
today What made a thing?
What poetry?
I'm a bitch, I'm a lover, I'm a dude child i'm a mother i'm
a sinner and a saint i do not feel the shame i'm your health
i'm your dream i'm nothing in between oh you want it want it
want it any other way oh it's tough for anybody it's like
hard oh guitar riff i can't i do the air guitar too since
i'm a child prodigy i'm an air guitar prodigy
I do air bass too!
But I do the air drums!
I'm the fucking Jackson by myself!
Ow!
Just when you think you've got me figured out The season's
already changing I think it's cool What you want to do And
you don't try I don't know this far, save me I'm a bitch,
I'm a lover I'm a child, I'm a mother I'm a sinner, I'm a
saint I do not feel ashamed I'm your health, I'm your dream
I'm nothing in between You know you wouldn't want it any
other way Like Burger King, have it your way I'm a bitch,
I'm a tease I'm a goddess, I'm a niece When you get hurt,
when you suffer I'm your angel undercover I'm enough
Leave?
What?
Leave the pain medication
to whoever's next.
Am I a superstar?
Yeah, this is my new job, guys.
You gotta get a new Z-Team, guys, because I'm like, I'm
opening, like, fuck Taylor, Taylor or something.
Oh, my God, this guy is shredded.
Oh, my God, I can't sit down yet.
Oh, he's still going.
Oh, my God.
I should go to the, what pedal is that?
I should go to the guitar center and figure it out.
was that everything you guys wanted i literally there was
somebody on reddit that was like i wrote out everything that
flamb did in his song and so i just literally read it out
as much as i could
yeah thank you my kamiosi for filling my request i think
i'll change my name to robert now i don't know i don't think
the song is very positive towards robert Robert.
Thank you, Reddit post.
Let's do the Chaplorone song.
Then maybe I'll go to Japanese songs for a bit.
But.
I'd say Robert got fairly wrecked.
Yeah, I think so, too.
Okay, she does, like, really high notes at the end of this.
I don't know if I'll do it.
It's also been a while since I've heard this song, so.
This is The Subway by Chapel Road.
I saw your green hair, beauty mark next to your mouth.
They're on the subway.
I nearly had a breakdown.
A few weeks later, somebody wore your perfume.
It almost killed me.
I had to leave the room.
It's just another room.
And it's not over till it's over.
It's never over.
It's just another day.
And it's not over till it's over.
And it's never over till I don't look for you on the
staircase.
Or wish you thought that we were still so much.
But I'm still counting down all of the days Till you're just
another girl on the subway Made you the villain, evil for
just moving on I see your shadow, I see it even with the
lights off I made a promise, if in four months this feeling
and ain't gone well fuck this city I'm moving to
Saskatchewan it's just another day and it's not over till
it's over oh till it's over it's just another day and it's
not over till it's over it's never over Till I can break
routine during foreplay And trust myself that I won't say
your name But I'm still counting down all of the days Till
you're just another girl on the subway She's got, she's got
away She's got away She's got away And she got, she got away
She got away, she got away She's got, she's got away She's
got away, she's got away
away she got away she got away she got away she's gone she's
gone away
and she got she got away she got away she got away she got
away
And she got, she got away,
she's got away, she's got away.
I feel like she held that note way longer in the original
song.
like the original like the that away part i feel like she
held it like crazy hmm hmm maybe i don't know first time i
heard this song thanks and i really like it yeah it's a
great song isn't it so like we yeah the last part right hmm
hmm oh well i'm always i always Always remain enchanted by
your voice, Minto.
That's why he's the best kamiyoshi.
Blue skies from Ace Combat 4.
Let me get to Ace Combat 4 first.
And then we'll sing Ace Combat songs.
Unless we do lag.
What's a word?
The 7 one.
Oh my gosh.
but i can't why can't i remember the name right now
daredevil yes daredevil
what is it with chaplain unrequited love songs i think she
like has someone just she just is not over for real
daredevil so stinking good if you ever if you've never
listened to ace combat music, just listen to Daredevil.
It's so good.
She's a professional yearner, for real.
I saw somebody requesting Abba.
Which one, which Abba should we do?
The Subway is one of my favorite songs in karaoke that I
listen to, I loop all the time.
I'm glad you managed the high notes this time.
Yeah, oh gosh, that's embarrassing though.
Dance it queen!
I love dance it queen.
Okay, one more sad song and then we'll end it on a happy
song and then we'll go to Japanese songs.
Song.
Oh, it starts immediately.
School bag in hand.
She leaves home in the early morning.
Waving goodbye with an absent-minded smile.
I watch her go with the surge of that well-known sadness and
I have to sit down for a while the feeling that I'm losing
her forever and without really entering her world I'm Glad
whenever I can share her laughter That funny little girl
Slipping through my fingers all the time I try to capture
every minute The feeling in it Slipping through my fingers
all the time Do I really see what's in her mind Each time I
think I'm close to knowing She keeps on growing, slipping
through my fingers all the time.
Sleep in her eyes, her and me at the breakfast table.
Breaking bad, barely awake, I let precious time go by.
Then when she's gone, there's that awe.
melancholy feeling and a sense of guilt I can't deny what
happened to the wonderful adventures the places I had
planned for us to go well some of that we did but the most
we did it I just don't know Slipping through my fingers all
the time I try to capture every minute The feeling in it
Slipping through my fingers all the time Do I really see
what's in her mind?
Each time I think I'm close to knowing She keeps on growing
Slipping through my fingers Sometimes I wish that I could
freeze the picture And save it from the funny trace of time
Slipping through my finger
School back in hand She leaves home in the early morning
Waving goodbye
minded smile
Come on
You can dance
Oh, see that girl Watch that scene Dig in the dancing queen
Friday night and the lights are lit
The night is young and the music's high Everything
is fine You're in the loop for a day And when you get the
chance You are the dancing queen Young and sweet forever 19
Dancing queen Feel the beat from the tambourine Oh yeah You
can dance You can shine.
Ooh, see that girl.
Watch that scene.
Take in the dancing queen.
You're a teaser, you turn him on.
You're in the mood for a dance.
And when you get the chance, you are the dancing queen.
And sweet forever 19 Dancing clean Feel the beat from the
tambourine Oh yeah You can dance You can drive Oh,
see that girl Watch that scene Digging the dancing queen
Let me grab my switch.
Joy sound.
Oh, uh.
Let me update my switch real quick.
I have a system update.
Please restart.
Oh, well, I do this.
I'm going to go grab some water real quick.
I'll be right super back.
Actually, I'm going to grab some water and go to the little
ghosty's room.
I'll be right back.
Welcome back, thank you!
Ta-da-da-ima!
So I should be saying to you, though.
Alright.
Karaoke.
Hasimere.
Hmm.
Now, here's the difficult part.
It's like, what do I start with with a...
Japanese karaoke.
Oh my gosh, it's been so long since I've done it.
I don't know Gundam songs.
I don't know why we have this impression.
Actually, I know one Gundam song.
I know one Gundam song.
I know a couple, but I know them enough to sing them.
But I know one that I can sing.
Mix.
Oh my gosh, it's been so long since I've heard two mix.
a Tumik song from Conan.
I could sing Detective Conan.
Oh my gosh, wait, it's been so long since I've sung
Detective Conan.
Stay with me, Miku, Matsubara.
Yeah, I'll write some of these down that I feel like
singing.
Stay with me.
That one's easy.
Now well, they get some whisper though.
Thank you to thank you.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Just communication.
I'm trying to remember what's from Conan.
I mean, they've had a couple Conan songs, but there's like
one specifically that I remember.
And they have two on here.
Oh, wait, they have more than two.
Just kidding.
I'm a liar.
Oh my god, Toomix did the song for the X-Files!
I guess in Japan?
What?
That's crazy!
Ending song for free and oh i'm sorry i don't know it enough
i'm sorry i think it was break from conan that was the big
one is it i think so maybe i would have to hear it hold on
let me uh oh shoot uh one second let me plug in my
then it should work splitter please work there we go
splitter to wrong and you should be to hear it.
Friday night singing.
Thanks for the music.
Thank you.
Thank you, Kava.
So thank you guys for the donos.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Sorry that the sound is off for them.
I'm going to listen to Break real quick.
Oh my god.
I think you're right.
Break my life.
Hold
on.
shop to the e-shop i have still many many credits because of
everybody who has donated in the past so thank you 90 days
no no no no no cancel where is
cancel please okay there we go three hours one day okay
we'll do the three hour version Do you need more?
Nope.
Thank you very much.
Wait, what did I just click?
No.
Oh my gosh, it just went backwards again.
Okay, get there.
Yes.
Yippee!
Soft on the modoloo.
Kaisi.
Switch sounds.
Hello?
Is it gonna go?
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Wait, do you guys want to see the screen or do you not care?
Oh my god.
Oh, I haven't heard this song!
And like, maybe...
Maybe like...
Oh my god, I don't even know how many years.
Like 15.
Break my lives,
Oh no, there's like the, what's it called, the delay.
So I can't follow it.
I have to read the words for real.
So to give a little bit lore about this song, this is a
Tumik song.
The voice actress for Conan is the singer of Tumik's, but
Conan, the character, is canonically tone deaf.
So there's like a funny episode where he has, everybody is
like, oh my gosh, Conan, you sound so much like this, like
this singer.
You have to cover for her because she can't do the concert.
And he's like, what the hell?
But he is tone deaf, so he sings the song, but it's her.
Technically singing the song, but she has to pretend to be
tone deaf.
It's so funny.
Breakdown lore drop,
yeah.
I guess maybe now would have been the better do it time to
do it because there's no singing but yeah
Oh my gosh, I love telling people about Conan lore because
it's just so wild If you ever want me to tell you about
Conan stuff.
I'm your ghost
Ravak thanks for the gift oh, oh I'm raiders.
Oh, thank you.
I'm so sorry to see hello
I love that
the only part I know this song I remember is the chorus
yeah that was a break by two mix you found the Conan clip
that's so funny wait I wanted to if I search Conan let's see
me me me tantay oh wait there it is tantay Conan
Oh, I love this song too!
Wait, I want to sing this one.
This one I've sung in karaoke before though, sorry.
Fiction by Sumigo.
Oh my gosh, I haven't heard that song in so long.
This is not the one that goes like...
That one?
Oh no, I forgot the music videos are so funny.
Oh no, okay, I try not to be distracting.
Furi-sou, two of you, you're overlapped In the cold wind,
the cold of the wind, you're overlapped, The freshness of
the warmth, now, stop.
Time to stop.
Yes, always the day, I'm going to forget your words.
I've been thinking about
I've been thinking about you.
Technically, this is a fall song or whatever.
.
over the years.
Stalk, do you remember say, it's time to see when I want to
when I want to see when I want to see soon it turns out I've
been thinking about you, I've been thinking about you I'm
always looking for you.
I am always looking for you, even more than what I'm
feeling.
Any time I'm looking for you, when it's now, I'm so nice and
I can be able to see that I'm going to have.
I'm thinking,
I've been thinking about you, I've been thinking about you.
Why are there no lyrics for that bar?
What are you?
They
left them off the screen.
Okay, so I've been really good about holding it in.
The music video for this one is a girl like joining a cult
maybe.
I think she joined a cult.
I think so.
She had, like, a cape on.
What was going on?
If you know about the barbarian, just ask Minto.
Wait, Ron Conan.
Ron Conan.
If you want to know about the talk host show.
Well, talk show host.
Oh, gosh.
Why am I so dyslexic?
Taco's joke.
Ah!
Why?
Oh, I'm sorry, I'm just going through the popular songs.
Wait, I want to sing this song.
The song is so hard.
I'm not good at singing it, but I like singing because it's
fun.
if I mess it up.
Sorry, sorry.
Sorry in advance.
It's such a good song though.
Everybody agrees.
10 out of 10.
You guys know this one.
I ran out of breath, sorry?
Turn that off!
Oh!
No more, no more, no more, no more No more, no more music
You're the one that you'll cause magic No more, you'll get
your heart I'd say it's forever, it's not your heart, you're
It's your heart What?
This song will tell you.
Do you wanna play real game?
Giri giri, tina wadari-like a sentence.
I don't want to be able to get back to my dream in the
dream.
I wanna be free.
I can see the new world.
The new world is the new world.
Okay,
now the guy is joining a cult.
He's in a robe too in the forest and he's burning music.
There are, there, I don't know what's going to be like that.
Real or colorful, you can't do that.
Music, now it's starting, rising.
I'm going to look at you.
I'm going to show you, I'm going to show you.
Oh my gosh, I can't do that.
I can't do that.
Do you want to play a real game?
Giri-giri, tina-wattari-minty-minty-nai-minty-nai I'm skip.
I don't want you.
I'm going to go back.
Let this dream in the new world.
I want to be free.
I can't believe it.
Find the life world, figure.
I believe the future will change it.
Dream the world  me.
I'm going to change it.
funny music video he's there's like feathers and then he
cuts a put a cut in his hand and There's black smoke coming
out of it.
I can't make this up.
I can't make it up.
I can't back it up.
I don't know what I was watching.
It was really distracting me.
Oh my gosh.
That's fine.
Crazy karaoke lore.
Crazy.
Morgan's Ghost.
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
I wish I could sing more fruit zipper songs.
They're so fun, but they're so fast.
I love One Piece.
I love Ado.
I love Mito.
Seeing New Genesis Live is a magical experience.
Oh my God, I would kill.
I want to see Ado Live.
It would be crazy.
I missed her when she was touring, so I'm like, no.
Yeah.
Do you think these silly karaoke videos have hidden lore,
like, just dance?
Just Dance has lore?
The only Rolling Star.
I think I tried singing that one before, and I was like...
I think I don't know this song as much as I thought.
You would think it's so easy.
I'm going to...
through some of the popular songs.
Naruto.
Let's see.
Oh, I'm trying to find songs that like.
That like.
What's the word?
You know the end song for Inu Yashu.
Which one?
I'm trying to find songs.
So because I have to pay for the service and i only get
three hours i like to choose songs that i don't get to sing
often you know like there's a bunch of songs that i like i
could choose that have like free karaoke on youtube you know
what i mean this thing new genesis was amazing but i guess
also Shinji Dai is also like it's also pretty easy to find
on youtube but whatever i love the sapikara for like ice
cream Sabikara means like just from the chorus.
So it's only the chorus of Ah, subkornim, subkornim,
subkornim, subkornim.
That's a good one.
Departure.
Oh my gosh, I wish I knew the song better.
So good.
Oh, gosh.
Why is Curious George on here?
Sounds like she needs more yen e-shop.
No, I don't.
I'm just explaining why sometimes you guys say give me songs
and I don't pick them.
Like God knows or Kimi no Shiranai Monogatari.
Those ones are easy to find instrumentals who are on YouTube
and they're free and this one's not free.
But I guess most of the popular songs would have like...
What's it called?
Would have karaoke's on YouTube.
Maybe.
But sometimes...
I don't know.
Yeah, let me look up Kotoko.
Let's do that.
You're so right.
Resublimity.
Wait, keywords.
There we go.
Kotoko.
K-O-T.
I wonder if there's any out here.
Let's see what's on here.
Kotoko.
She was like my Like, favorite singer for so long.
I love her voice so much.
Oh, no, I'm getting...
Okay.
Oh, there's like an Onigai teacher, shooting star.
Well, there is resublimity on here.
Oh, wait, there's actually so many on here.
Oh, my God.
But there's also like a mix...
There's like this artist named Toko Toko.
I guess he's like a Vocaloid producer.
And he...
There's a bunch of songs featuring Goomi on him.
There you are!
Oh, I can see if it's on here.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Shurling star.
The song is so stinking good.
I've sung this one in karaoke, though, but it's still good.
The song is so good.
Oh, my God.
The intro...
Peak, iconic, everything about it, so good.
.
Just by the way you feel stronger, it's a feeling of regret.
One more time, one more time, don't let me know about you in
a big, one of you, one of you, one of you, when you're at a
time I'm just making up words at this point, sorry, I'll
lock in, I'll lock in.
I'll lock in.
Let us go together to be together I'm going to use the glass
in a glass box And I'll always be able to pray for you in
the night And I love you with your smile And I'm so excited
to see how it will be.
When it comes to you, I'll remember you.
I'll remember you.
In a huge universe, I found two of you and I found a happy
place to find you.
And here are the stars and the stars and the two of you.
The night of the wind and the you and the
The music video is so stinking cute, it's like about a
magical girl and a psychic girl who both like the same guy
and they're like trying to make him win at soccer.
Show you the video?
Okay.
I'll put it in the corner.
You see why I keep getting distracted?
She's got hearts in her eyes, just like I do.
Oh my God, is he okay?
What's happening?
Use your magic, save him!
Oh my god!
Oh
my god, don't end it on a cliffhanger, please.
That's not what I expected at all.
Why did I thought she would- Oh my god, he's not gonna- Oh
my god, he's not gonna make it!
She is- Oh my god, that's gonna take forever for her to
build the bridge.
You have magical powers!
And you turn it to...
Oh, it's too good!
Holy cow!
It's so funny.
Okay, I'm really glad I showed you guys that one.
Or else I would have just been laughing to myself.
Oh!
There we go.
Oh my god.
How does resublimity go again?
it for some reason my brain keeps thinking of separation
because that's one of my favorite kotoko songs and that's my
favorite song from kanazuki no mika he'll return in avengers
dude oh sad oh
wait isn't the song like really fast wait yeah this song is
really fast wait i think i'm not gonna be able to do it wait
hold on
The existence is certainly here and here I'm waiting for the
tears and tears I won't let you know the moment I can't
hear, can't hear, can't hear I can't see, I can't see, just
My heart goes away
My voice, my voice, my voice, my voice My voice doesn't come
to me
This song is hard.
This song almost makes the instrumental sound like, or this
instrumental almost makes the sound like the song
unrecognizable.
I'm so sorry I got the timing all wrong on this song, holy
cow.
hard hold on though i saw like a way that you can search
things in this it's kind of fun like look at this so if you
go so if i go to here and if i go to my history and if i go
to here and if i go to like the search we could search from
the same same release year which it worked
What else I released in 2000?
What was it?
Oh no!
Oh my gosh, no!
Oh my gosh, it's almost time to sing that song, though.
These are all songs that were released in 2004.
Go!
Natsukaji, Natsukaji!
Beauty honey!
Oh my god, ready, steady, go!
Ready, steady, ready,
steady!
Ready, steady, ready, ready, ready, ready, ready!
I wish we could try it, we could try it.
I'm not gonna sing it well, but we'll try it.
Gakumash!
No, I'm sorry.
No Gakumash.
Yeah, 2004 was a great year for Annie's song, it's so true.
Ready, steady, can't hold me back.
Ready, steady, give me good luck.
Ready, steady, can't give her a hug back.
Let's get started, ready, steady, go.
Before it goes out to the place where it's hard to see at
least a few enemies.
I won't be looking at my end.
Ate-to-near-narr-nay, cheese, I can't get it back.
It's all over the truth.
In my hands on my hands, I'm so so so, so M-tool, and I'm
so, I'm so happy to go to the world.
It's a very loud, hard-sake-sone, like a dodo-no-kata-nari
It's like the sound of your voice There's no time for you to
stop, but there's no time for you.
I'm ready, steady, go!
I'm out
I'm just counting I'm just so glad I'm not alone The story
is so loud Even though I'm still no doubt On that black
light On that red red light I was able to hear I was just
like that You know all things like that I'm just in an I'm
just enjoying I'm so excited
The song is so good.
Very steady, can't hold me back.
Ready, steady, give me good luck.
What's
going on in this music video?
I don't know.
So crazy.
It's so crazy.
Never know what's going on in these music videos.
Like, when did they, why did they film them is the biggest
question to me.
Like, what is, what is, oh, I guess I should have adjusted
the key before I did the song, but that's okay.
That's one thing I forget you can do on here.
Like, I just...
Oh, someone requested Inno Yasha earlier.
I want to do Inno Yasha.
And then also... Wait, okay, there's a couple of...
Natsukashi...
Wait, wrong one.
Sorry.
A couple of nostalgic songs that I was thinking of.
Inno Yasha!
Maybe they're trying to escape the cold.
Oh my gosh, there's so many.
There's quite moody, but...
I don't know.
This one's easy to find.
Brand new world!
I want to change the world.
I remember they had Ready City Go as the final song in the
original Owen Dandias game.
Wait, really?
That's awesome.
Oh, sorry.
I keep forgetting to turn off turn off the dang camera.
Shinjits no, it's probably most likely.
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
How does this one go?
I love Yuda Yuda!
Wait, can I sing this one?
This one's from the movie!
It's one of my favorite movies.
My favorite Inuyasha movie.
Is it okay?
I love this song.
I'll try the Chidits No Uta after.
The world is all over the world, in the world.
Bang, bang, bang.
Looking for the world.
A love-in-law's antennae, with a wish, bang, bang.
A gloomy sky is clear, with the light that's all light.
What the hell?
No one knows what's wrong.
A blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue.
iral hero I of my wick I
knew that In a very normal season,
I'm slowly sabotaging it.
It's not just in our own life, and it's not you.
No matter what you know, no matter what you know, all the
small stars just go and you go out and go.
Oh, on your way to your friends.
Now, I
threw me off, man.
Saga-septi-mortem-tah-quickly-mortemly-noyant-noying
Negray-committer.
Gumbory-solar-w-tooking-nook-thickety-hickery-sac-shy-thickery.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
The cat looks way worse than the bunny.
The cat looks so scary in the bunnies.
My god.
Just him appearing out of nowhere.
Wow.
I thought it was like a normal music video.
It's so funny.
Oh.
So.
funny.
Peaking behind the tree is so scary.
Oh, wait.
I want just Inuyasha, not Inuyasha movie.
Dang it.
Wait, what is this one?
What was the other song in that movie?
Oh, I'm gonna listen to it.
Wait.
The thing that's also really difficult, I'm trying to make
excuses for why i keep messing up but like the timing is off
because there is the since i'm watching through obs so do
you remember this song
oh this song was so good i remember
yeah oh my gosh
I was able to hear the sound of my life.
I remember it all.
It was a warm, warm feeling, it was all about all about my
body.
I couldn't hear anyone's voice, but I couldn't hear my
voice.
Wait, am I getting that right?
Don't be eating that right?
Don't be that bad.
No,
no.
Don't be.
Don't be such a
mean like, right?
I will be right here.
Our fallout is a chitzy And we're all
there, it's a chitzy The hands of the That's not where we're
at That's where our planet The earth can't Ever since we
knew There's no But where we go wherever we go Any time, any
time, any place, any place, there is a certain love that is
true.
So, it's not just about the saddest, it's about the saddest,
it's about the love of the world.
It's a warm, warm, warm,
what's this guy doing oh my gosh i can't believe oh my gosh
i don't know the last time i heard the song the song plays
when they're like they're like at the camp Oh my god, I love
this movie.
It's so good.
He's thinking about cult.
He's just like skinny pea.
You're right.
You're
right.
.
Don't be a lie to me right now.
Come here,
come here, come here to see me.
In this world, What are you seeing?
What are you seeing?
Is that Tama Shite?
Tama Shite?
Isn't that right?
Wait, Wait, I don't know.
Oh my gosh.
No, Koshite.
I'm wrong then.
Man.
Oh, he's so sad.
My kanji.
I need to remember my kanji
I just okay I don't know if I'll sing I don't know if I'll
sing the song since to know what that but I'll try
I'll be honest guys I never really liked Kaimori I think
it's like a nostalgia thing that I like it, but...
But I just, I don't know...
I'll try.
We've had this music video like 10 times now.
I've seen it all.
Now, now, now, now, now, this is the way I'm drawing in the
sun, the sky and the sky is the only I'm only here for you
to find my life.
I'm more than I can get you.
I'm more so now, I'm stronger, I'm more than you are now, to
do.
I'm just so small and just I'm going to hurt myself.
You're hurting me.
So you're only one.
No, we got the lesbians!
I'm sorry.
.
For example, someone's Yes, a smile, For a long time, If you
die, No doubt, No doubt, No, No, No, No, No, No, No, No No
No, No, I'm gonna go back to the sky, someday I'll get to
know the truth of the song as a sign of the way to make it
and forever and forever, all the dark, the pain will always
disappear and the truth of the world and the world me
Oh my gosh, that song is hard.
Never mind.
I'm not going to sing that one again.
But the Yuri was happening.
Nice.
Um, but mum, mum, mum, mum, mum, mum, mum, mum, mum.
What's like another?
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the rhythm, rag!
Soft, soft, tender.
Thank you!
For your consideration, can I submit Hatsukoi Sider or
Katsuki?
calendar girl.
Oh, I could do a calendar girl because how to go inside her
is very easy to sing.
Let's do calendar girl.
Cal.
I love calendar girl.
Hmm.
Actually, well, no, I shouldn't have searched calendar girl.
I think there's like more than one.
There you go.
Thanks for the fun guitar.
I cut.
The song is fun.
Or the dance is fun too.
Wait, I'm probably gonna butcher it.
It's It's hard to sing as one person, but I'll do my best.
Maybe they'll do the effects for me.
Sunday, Monday, Choo Choo Choo Day Makeup with the calendar
card My every day Wednesday, Thursday, Friday, Saturday It's
not gonna be a brand
new I don't like seeing I'm getting a lot of choo-choo
Double, double-choo I don't want to do any more What's your
name?
Bane, bane, A-B-A-B-A-B-A-R-E Let's have a can of candy I
want to eat Caffeo-R-E-N-S-T-E Ribbon D-R-E-N-S-Y-O-K-R-K
It's already YAB-I-E It's time, sunshine Oh, my god, good
luck Oh, thank you Oh, thank you Oh, thank you, thank you
Oh, thank you Oh
That song is so cute You should listen to the original
because it's so good The song is so cute calendar girl from
Aikatsu.
Aikaru Katsu though.
But the music video?
Oh my gosh, wait, it reminded me of something.
I wonder if they have...
They should.
I'm trying to decide how I want to search it.
Japanese music videos look like they were very economical to
produce.
Well, these are like, they're specifically made for Joy
Sound for like the karaoke.
So they're not... I want to call the music videos but...
I forgot what I was gonna look up.
What's another?
Um...
What's another...
What does he...
Oh my gosh, wait, I don't remember how that goes.
Oh yeah, wait, let's do it!
Let's try...
He...
Let's see what Higurashi is talking to him.
Wait, oh they have...
Wait, boy.
I like how they...
Look at this.
They specifically have Higurashi no Nakakoroni, slot, and
pachinko.
Let me try...
Wait, I don't...
Can you do more than just those?
Sotsu and Gyo-goo?
This is caught...
Wait, Higurashi...
I'm just gonna look up Higurashi no Nakakoroni itself and
not click.
I'm gonna...
Kolo, Kolo, Kolo, Kolo, Kolo, Kolo, Kolo.
Where's Kolo?
Oh, I'm stupid.
Kolo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo, lo.
That should be enough.
Ah!
That's fine.
Oh my god, this is wrong by Asaka!
I love Asaka!
I love Asaka, I love Asaka.
I love Asaka.
Oh my gosh, this song, this next to this, reminded me of
happy material.
Did they have Dario?
They don't!
Why?
They don't even have like you.
They don't have any of the you songs.
Why?
Interesting.
That's crazy.
Kami-sama no syndrome is really good too.
I like the songs from the new series a lot.
What do I say?
Because I love her.
Wait, do I remember how this goes?
What?
I believe in what you said I want to know where I want to
go.
A clear, clear, clear, clear, I've always loved your joy,
and always your your tears, even more, more than any other,
much-riga-nigh-nigh in the feeling the memories.
Just one, The music video?
Hello?
Oh!
I'm getting distracted, I'm getting seduced right now.
I believe what you say, When I opened my eyes, my eyes were
red, my eyes were red, and my eyes were red.
My eyes were red, and my eyes were red.
I wanted to know more about you, and I wanted to follow you.
Unnatural, unsoverely, no-mong-nothing.
I used the words.
This song is so hard.
But not me, I'm focused.
.
I get it girl!
You're so sexy!
Thinking this was the right choice!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, nice.
Yeah.
She was so sexy.
Hot there.
I don't know.
Wow, it's already been three hours.
Let's see.
What else do I want to sing?
I'm just thinking.
I'm going to sing.
What?
Wake up, girl.
Wake, wake.
Wake up, girls.
Thinking of eye cuts.
I don't think I'll wake up, girls.
Nope.
Wake up, girls.
No!
Wait, maybe...
Let me try, like, searching, oh, a song name.
Thanks so much for feeling my Hugo Rashi brain worms.
Sorry that they didn't have any of the U songs.
Let's try.
Let's see...
Uh...
Maybe we can go from there.
It's that first one right there.
Hey!
Why don't you show up?
Hello?
I'm angry.
Why don't you show up?
.
I'd love to be on the bottom, too.
Ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba kiss me.
Bokura no frontier.
I know it, but I don't remember it.
Did you think Robert is a bitch?
Yeah, you missed it.
I'll sing this.
When I do 3D next.
Seven senses.
Oh, I do kind of remember this one.
It was not my favorite.
I don't know pound cake.
Have you sung any Dempogumi today?
No, we'll sing it right after.
Let's do Seven Girls' War.
That's a, that's a...
I'm gonna wake up, I'm happy, I'm happy, I'm happy Take it
all!
Three, two, one, go!
Big, big, big, changing Changing That's it, I'm gonna
do it first, I'm gonna take one step, I'm gonna do it Let's
go, let's go!
My dream is still, still, It's so far I'm not gonna be
there, But I'm more happy
And tomorrow Woohoo Da-hoo Da-ha-ha Da-me-na-koto-no
Japanese Da-keto-tun-tun Sibata-pari-de-tomodach Ech-chan-un
I always stop it I always forget I'm the
best I'm the best I'm the best UZI NAYAMI NANDT FUKEY TABASI
The girl Just can't let her The magic The magic For you One,
two, three, four One, two, three One, two, three One, one
One, challenging Challenging Challenging That's a Jimmy Not
easy But But
And then you
look at your partner and you nod.
And then every- I'm happy, happy, happy, happy, happy, I'm
happy, I'm happy, I'm happy.
But, hey, I'm with you, I'm happy, you're all together.
My tears are all seven stars and all change.
Gagallay, Gagallay, Gagallay.
I'm back, I'm back.
That's how I learned songs, or that's how I learned dances.
That's how I, that's my little process in my head.
I'm like, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da,
da.
What did I say?
I was gonna look for after Wug?
I don't remember.
Thanks for sliding, boss.
Oh, cool!
So...
Waguna dattan naka.
So desu!
Miu-chan osi desu.
Denpa-gumi!
Song requests are at your days?
Probably not this time.
Because that one's very easy for me to sing.
But there's lots of...
of karyokis of it, so I can sing it anytime.
What tempo song should we sing?
I do have a Christmas song.
Orange over here.
Their songs are very difficult, though.
That's passion you won't you're right i won't because it's
too hard hey yo damn it's too hard
no more cute
they put this on here
They put WWD ending?
This is their final...
So this is one of my...
This is my favorite idol group, basically.
One of my favorite idol groups, but...
They...
They disbanded...
Basically, almost a year ago today.
Like, they disbanded a year ago this month.
Like, it was a...
It was just after New Year's.
They have WWD...
This is their final song!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, it's too sad!
Yeah, so they- so basically the group- I did a whole
karaoke, a whole Dumpa gloomy karaoke if you want to hear
more Dumpa songs.
Um, but see they have WWD2 here, and then they have a WWD
somewhere.
Somewhere.
WWD.
And then they had- because they are worldwide DEMPA and WWD
is kind of about how the girls all met so the mains the not
the original six but the the group had like a originally had
well the core group was originally six girls that's where
most people knew them as and each girl was kind of like a
loner otaku like type like they kind of were that don't fit
in they get bullied and everything like that and so WWD was
about their stories about each person and uh and everything
and how they met and and it's so like emotional and how they
just want to be idols like they Dempogumi changed the idol
industry and I don't mean that like in a in like I'm not
exaggerating literally at all like before Dempogumi like
idols had such a different image and then these girls were
older and they were like not your typical like everything
was so different about them and uh and just so much that
they've done for the industry is just amazing and um heck
yeah yeah they're awesome and so you know they did they had
wwd which was It's just like, we're not your conventional
girls, but one day we're going to shine big horn stage.
They're like, we're right now on this tiny little stage
because they started at deer stage.
And then they're like, one day we'll make it big.
And they did.
They did.
And then WWD too is kind of more about their struggles, but
more so like, just like, you know, am I even necessary?
Like do I need it here?
Like things like that.
And they're just like, yeah.
Nyaru!
Thank you for the read the work!
Hello, hello!
Sorry, I'm giving history lesson on Dempogumi Inc right now.
So...
Yeah, so that was like WWD2.
And then they had WWD Best, and WWD Best was right before
they went on like a big hiatus.
And after that hi- in the midst of that hiatus, one of the
core six members left.
And it was like, everyone was like, oh my gosh, is this
dope?
And this felt, WWD best, it feels like an ending song, you
know?
So.
Dorygo, thank you so much for the five!
Gifted, thank you.
I'm not looking for difficulty, no, no.
I mean, difficulty in trying to find a karaoke of it is what
I mean.
Thank you, Scypto, thank you so much for the gift.
And so, then they came back and they had like a new, not a
whole new lineup, but they added a few new members.
got a bit rocky it was a little tough for them they kept
losing members and changing members and things and such now
i think it's a bit true that i get it but they really did i
feel like they had to come back they had a really you know
but they just couldn't hold it like hold the same popularity
they did in their prime so last year they decided to end the
group and it was so sad
song i've that's all i've been singing i've only been
singing any song literally i think i don't i have not sung a
japanese song that was not any song maybe one day they do
like a little reunion concert well i was i i couldn't go
unfortunately but right now they're doing like an exhibition
where um they have they have like concert they did It's
called like, they did a, they did a show where it was like a
bunch of people that create, that created things for Dempa.
They came together and did like a show and stuff.
And right now they have like the old shutter from Deer
Stage.
It broke.
So right now it's on display with a bunch of Dempa, um, old
uniforms and costumes and stuff.
And yeah, so.
It's been nice.
Yeah.
That's why it's just been blank recently?
Yeah, yeah, that's why it's been blank.
I don't even know if I could sing this.
I just want to hear it though.
I want to hear how the karaoke sounds.
This is my passion.
Actually that calendar girl song that I did, that was also
sung by a member of Deer Stage.
Oh my god.
This is about how they were a group for 16 years and now
it's over.
.
I
can't sing the song at all.
It's so cool.
These are the members.
I am being
totally selfish and just listening to this for myself.
This is the song.
This is the melody from WWD.
Thank you.
That bakumi eek so good!
Nailed it!
Yeah!
My voice is just about giving out.
That was fun?
Should we do one last song?
What would be a good song to end on?
One that I can properly...
properly sing.
Hmm...
I don't want to sing baka mita right now because I just did
it.
If you could listen to my cover...
Sorry, I don't mean to like...
reject all your songs, but...
Song from... My song from Angel Beats, you know what's
interesting is like...
You won't find any...
Songs from key properties on here.
I think it's... I think it's the singer.
Leah like doesn't like putting stuff on.
Like let's see, if I search...
What's a...
Clonad.
Let's see, I could...
Thank you for the dinosaur ride before your karaoke!
You see, it doesn't even come out.
Let me try in English.
Oh, whoops.
It should, it should like, work though.
Even in Japanese.
You'll see.
Isn't that crazy?
That's why it's very difficult for me to sing, like, key
songs, because they just don't put them on here for some
reason.
Please keep being selfish.
It's always so fun when you're being selfish.
Thank you for letting me be selfish today.
This was an extremely selfish karaoke because I...
I... I only...
I only sung the dinosaur stuff.
Thank you for letting me be so selfish today.
All Dino songs Whatever doesn't make your voice died Yeah
I'll take it easy The next couple of days I'll have to take
it easy for the next couple of weeks For my jazz show Yeah
Oops all dino's Has been very fun When you're having fun
We're having fun Yeah What?
What's a song that I'm not?
It's more fun this way when you sing whatever you want,
Minto.
Thank you!
We love your song selection.
You're singing, My Soul is Healed.
Really?
Thank you.
There are more tickets coming out for that.
They're super sold out.
Yes, there's gonna be a second show!
There will be a second show, so you can get tickets to that.
Or there is the streaming show.
I always appreciate Aminto karaoke.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Yeah, yeah.
I enjoy myself immensely.
I hope you do these selfish karyokis in the future.
Thank you.
Second show, same venue?
Yeah, it's even the same day and everything.
Hold on, I'm getting in-spill from my room.
Which is mostly Metal Gear.
Wait.
I don't think I could sing anything, but...
I want to sing a song that I could properly...
I want to finish on something I could properly sing, so I'm
not like...
You know?
Thank you for the beautiful karaoke, chilling with you and
hearing your lovely voice is the very best.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mordo.
Kaisuma, thank you.
This is another idol group I really, really like.
Nezino cookies adore.
Oh, yo, yo, yo.
This song is so fun.
Oh.
Fiction by Sumika.
Probably not this time, but thank you.
Don't want to be da, da, da, da, da, for the for the last
song.
I'm trying to think of another song.
Hold on.
I'm looking around my room for inspiration, and it's a bunch
of metal gear.
Dang it.
Oh wait, I don't
know.
It's like, oh, Koharu, I want to...
It's yeah, it's a bunch of Metal Gear Blue Archive shoot.
Macros.
I feel like most that I sing of macros, macros.
You, I can get on YouTube.
It's hard when you have so many options.
It's tough.
You cannot board none.
I've never sung that one before.
Thank you for the ticket, dude!
I just wanted a cover.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Special.
Let's not wait.
I wonder if they have the Nyanyan medley.
Oh my god, there's 24 pages!
Crazy, crazy work.
I mean, I guess since I put in macros, that would give me
literally every...
Every series of macros.
So, it makes sense.
Oh, it makes sense.
Wee!
Now I'm just looking.
Now I'm just browsing.
Thank you for the karaoke, Mito.
Always love your singing when you share passions with us,
Mito cute.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Really appreciate it.
Oh my gosh, didn't they have live versions of the song?
Holy cow.
This is the one that we sung recently with Phoebe.
She did this song at...
the anime wiki that I learned of.
Yes.
I love the Blessed Little Queen version.
I'm gonna go Nick here.
20 more months!
21 more months!
Thank you!
Obama style!
I wanna pick something that I'm very confident in here,
guys.
That's why I'm having so much trouble.
Because it's like hard to find stuff that I haven't sung
before, or that I can't sing very often, but also that I'm
confident in.
Because, I mean, I was limited for so long.
I forgot so much because I was always like, oh gosh, I can
only pick from like these 10 songs.
So I was limited for so stinking long.
Sing the original Macross theme.
I started going through that series not too long ago.
The song is so cool.
I don't remember how it goes.
We're chilling.
Are you?
One more anime song recommendations.
Yeah, if you just throw out stuff, I might get inspired.
I'll either, like, remember something or...
Can you rap?
No.
Actually, yeah, I'm a rap queen.
Send you on the save Valentine.
They don't have it on here.
They don't have it.
Look at the root cafe.
Shut up.
Don't mess her up.
Thank you so much for the fun.
Good dude.
Didn't remember love.
I could do that one because they have it right here, but
then they also have the blessed little queen version.
Such a good song.
Niyohime!
Oh my gosh, I was listening to that one last night.
I was like, oh, should I sing this tomorrow?
But that's like, I don't know if it was an ending song.
Na da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da.
Make sure this karaoke be cute.
It's always a treat to hear you sing when you guys should
buy your special interest.
Thank you!
Hunter Hunter first opening.
That's the one earlier that I was just like, I wish I could
sing this one.
I wish I knew it better.
I feel like, I think I only know the chorus.
Hacking to the key!
Toradora.
That gives me an idea.
Oh, whoop, whoop, whoop, whoop.
Oh, don't, don't, don't search, don't search it.
Tor, toda.
That gives me an idea.
I don't know.
They'll say well enough, but I know it.
Okay, hold on.
This is my idea.
Okay, watch this.
It came out in 2009.
Let's see what anime we got in here.
Romeo and Cinderella.
Oh my god, Kimi no Shinanai Monogatari.
Only my railgun.
Look, look, look at night fever.
Wow!
Butterfly!
Like the butterfly!
No.
That was way...
No, that's not the right butterfly.
Melt is so good too, though.
Oh, bangers.
I know.
It's kind of fun to just search by a year and be like, oh my
god.
Oh my god!
Bad apple!
Funky monkey babies!
Oh my god.
But I don't know.
I don't think I know.
Don't say lazy.
Wow.
Taylor Swift.
Lady Gaga bad romance.
Please, bad apple.
Okay, I will do bad apple.
What version?
What version is this?
Okay.
Yeah, I gotta do the McDonald's version.
This song always means
me need to spit i can't i can't swallow my spit because it's
so there's still time
That's it, that's it.
You're looking for me, nobody's looking for me.
I'm talking about my own words, my own words.
I'm sad, I'm tired of it.
I'm not feeling anything, I'm just going to spend it all.
The golden words are given, but my own words are just a
little.
It's just a wago-sola.
If I'm from the world, if I'm going to move it, then I'll
change it.
If I'm going to grow it, If you want me to go around me, if
I want to go around me If I'm feeling sad, if I'm sad, then
I'm a bad boy My heart is blacker than you.
You know me, I know me, and I know everything about you I
don't know how to open my eyes.
If I open up my eyes to go around me, I grow from the dark
to darken it.
I feel like I'm gonna get abs from this song.
I have to like...
I have to breathe so properly with it.
Holy cow.
Wait, I'm gonna go back to 2009.
Please?
Send me back.
Sorry I messed up a couple times.
Oh my gosh.
Ew, I can baby!
Oh, Stinking Boy.
Oh, my God.
The 2009 version of Cruel Angels Leases.
Maybe.
This is the song that basically, well, not.
It's like one of the songs that like put AKB48 on the map.
And River!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, I'll end with this song.
AKB48 River.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you so much.
I heard the opening notes for Bad Apple and shot out of bed
like a sleeper-raging Glory to me, though.
Yay!
Okay.
Sorry, I'm ending on a selfish song again, but the song is
so good.
The song is so good.
Okay.
All right.
Last song, for real.
River by Ake before the end.
Is this song hard?
Maybe.
Ake.
B
Oh 48 Boom The backing vocals The backing vocals Good, one
step, step it up, believe yourself Whip,
straight, straight, straight, face down, Fujisan It's always
a dream, It's a long way, It's not going to be the same It's
a long way to feel The feet of the feet of the One of the
people with the A big smile, big smile The big smile No, no,
no, no.
The river's wide, and wide, big, big, big, big dark, deep,
but the water's fast, I don't know, I'm not afraid, I'm not
afraid, but I'm afraid.
Yeah, there's no, there's more.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, don't do it.
YAMI, no, no, no, okay.
That's right.
Flip.
Take it up.
There's a future.
There's no way.
No, no, no, don't.
Don't give up.
The hole in the middle of the world has the dreams.
It's a dream to make a dream the world can't hear any It's a
very hard thing to see.
The heart of your heart is a hard, It's a hard, but it's a
hard thing.
It doesn't work out how it can't get me, I'm always there.
It's not going to be like you.
Don't give up.
There's a place where there's a place.
I'll never get over it We are I'll be able to make it I
don't know I'll be going to go, I'll be going, I'll be I'll
go through the way I've got the way to make it Oh, my mind's
a cover The cover's wide, big, and big, big, big dark, dark
and high, but I don't have to be afraid you Ah, that's
right, yeah yeah, that's the way the world more, more and
more more more more more more more
I'm gonna be worried about even though never let me even,
even even more even more
You can do it!
That song is all about never giving up, always believing in
yourself If you fail, you can try, try again You can cross
the river Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye,
bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, thank
you so much, thank you, bye-bye, bye-bye, thank you,
bye-bye, thank you, bye-bye, thank you, thank you,